Your area candidate.
You're in Toronto right
now and Justin Trudeau,
he interrupts a woman at a town hall.
She's asking you a question and he didn't
like one of the words that she used.
Listen to the sound bite and
then we'll get your reaction.
Right.
So that's why we came here today to ask
you to also look into the policies that
religious charitable organizations have
in our legislation so that it can also
be changed because maternal love is the
love that's going to change the future
of mankind.
So we'd like you to look,
we would like to say people kind,
not necessarily mankind for inclusive.
There we go.
Exactly.
And the crowd roars.
Yeah,
well it's quite a,
it's quite the performance.
I mean,
I'm afraid that our prime minister is
only capable of running his ideas on a few
very narrow ideological tracks.
We saw the first evidence of that
when he put his cabinet together,
he insisted upon making it 50% women,
despite the fact that only about
22% of the elected mps were women.
And it was easier for him to do that
than it was for him to screen people for
the sort of competence that would actually
be necessary to be cabinet members.
So we've seen a fair bit of this behavior,
but that was the most egregious example
I suppose our prime minister's great
example of that.
So back I think it was in
2015 he announced that half
of his cabinet was going
to be women because it was 2015 or
something like muddle headed virtue
signaling,
signaling excuse for north thinking.
I think only 20% or 25% of
the elected mps were female.
So the proper balance on
average would it be 25% female,
75% male.
What he should've done
was figured out who,
what all of these would make for a
competent cabinet minister because it's
actually quite important to have competent
cabinet ministers and then selected
from among his people for
nothing other than competence,
but he could virtue signal and then
he set up the most important board,
let's say of the entire comp country
on a cause I random basis Jesus.
How pathetic.
He should have been pilloried
by Canadians for that.
But we're so clued out and,
and also in the situation
that you described,
it's like if I say,
well,
50% of Trudeau's cabinet
shouldn't have been women.
It's like,
oh,
you're a misogynist.
It's like no,
only 25% of the elected
officials were women.
Now you might say,
well it would be better if
50% of the were elected.
It's like maybe it would be better,
but it didn't happen.
So you can't,
you can't fix it at the top end.
It was appalling.
So it's a hard argument to make you
because you need to know that there's more
difference within groups then between
in order to be able to come up with a
credible argument,
you know?
And then so yeah,
I think that the Trudeau government
is far to the left of where people
originally assumed it would be.
I mean,
I think that his decision to put 50%
women in the cabinet was an abdication of
responsibility of a magnitude that,
that we haven't seen before
in Canadian political history.
Only 26% of the,
of the MPS elected were female.
And that should have been approximately
the proportion of cabinet members.
But to say this is 2015 or
whatever the hell the year was.
And then to abdicate his responsibility
for selecting the most competent people
was an indication of exactly how,
uh,
what would you say,
how suited he is to be prime minister.
And people just didn't make much of an
issue of that because of their attempts
to be tolerant.
But I think that what he did was re,
oh,
I thought the fact that he ran to begin
with was reprehensible because he ran
entirely on the name brand recognition
that he had derived from his father.
And I think that that's the mark
of someone who's narcissistic.
You shouldn't have done that or
very charismatic and attractive and
he knows how to behave in public.
And so Andy had a very,
very famous name and,
but I believe that it was immoral
of him to run because the,
we're not dynasties democracies
aren't dynasties and he hadn't the um,
the CV,
the,
the record of success that you would
need as an independent individual to
justify himself as a qualified
candidate for prime minister.
So I thought that is his candidacy right
from the start was ethically flawed
then to,
to multiply that error with these,
these,
uh,
shallow attempts at
broadcasting tolerance,
especially at the expense of competence
and the capacity to truly evaluate is
just inexcusable.
Inexcusable.
Look,
it's unbelievably widespread.
So I'll give you an example that's very,
that's very similar.
Our Prime Minister,
Justin Trudeau announced in 2015 that
half the cabinet that he put together
would be women,
right?
The fact that only approximately,
I think it was 20 to 25% of the
elected officials were female.
And so what he basically admitted
as far as I'm concerned are,
was two things.
Number one,
he was incapable of judging people on
their competence because when you put
together something like the
cabinet for our country,
what you do is you find the most
competent people period because
it's so bizarre that it even has to be
said because it actually turns out that
the cabinet is important and so to me
all he did was default on his see his
central moral obligation to screen every
single one of his members of parliament
with exceeding care and to pick the most
qualified people and his rationale was
that it was 2015 you know,
so and we to reduce
competence to racial ethnic,
gender identity,
something like that is
absolutely appalling.
Move philosophically as well.
As far as I'm concerned to assume that
diversity is somehow represented by group
membership.
There's no evidence for that.
There's absolutely no scientific
evidence for that whatsoever.
In fact,
the scientific evidence
suggest quite the contrary,
which is that there's more variability
within groups than there is between
groups,
which is actually an antidote
to the central racist claim.
Right.
Because the central racist claim is,
there's more difference between groups
than there is difference within them.
And so,
you know,
you seen one black person,
you've seen them all.
We lock people who've already done that.
Okay,
that's interesting.
So you're saying it's
a necessary transition.
You're saying that something about the
life that he ended up saying something
simple.
If you can't make your damn bed quit
Wavell black cards at corporations,
it's like Jesus.
It's like seriously?
It's like,
what the hell?
What makes you,
you can't get this tiny
little part of the world.
It's actually right at
your feet functional.
You have contempt for it.
It's just my bedroom seems like grits
shoots this caricature of people.
I mean,
look,
they're there.
Flip on that is,
look,
why should I waste my time making my bed
when we got to deal with his problems
in the world?
You know what gives you risk inflating
your own ego by dealing with the problems
of the world.
It's the cathedral problem again.
It's like,
oh,
I shouldn't be at the
center of the universe.
Right?
So it's like,
yeah,
well maybe,
maybe not.
I'm trying to find a resolution of this,
that that goes beyond the existing
cultural conflict around it.
Because no doubt people need to attend
to their own projection and their own
limitations and have humility and some
psychological insight and work harder on
what they're directly responsible for.
I don't doubt that,
but I am concerned with a message that
says that's all you should be doing.
And until you figure that out,
anything else you should be doing your
thing you have to do at first or you can
do that.
You should be very leery of assuming
that when you try to do something else,
you won't just make it
worse and you will look.
I've dealt with people who've dealt with
complex systems for a very long period
of time and I know the difference between
someone who can make a complex system
better and someone who will make a
complex system worse and most people will
make a complex system worse.
Okay.
That's for sure that that's okay.
That's good because that's coming to
the question of development and the
question of human maturation and the
question of what it means to unfold
throughout the lifespan.
So just to,
just to try and distill that last point,
you're sort of saying don't begin and
end with your own responsibility of
cleaning your room and sorting your
personal and immediate fares out,
but realize that until you can do that,
you may be lacking a certain forms of
competence that might make you die.
Whether you should be
quite so visceral and,
and adamant about your political views.
Precisely that.
Yes,
and it's exactly the opposite of what
students are taught in universities.
But you're not saying don't care
about those things or don't act on,
but just while you're doing them,
attend to your own
limitations and competencies.
Well I'm saying you should be aware of,
you should be aware of your
own competence and your limits.
Right.
And that that's especially
true if you're very young.
Cause like what the hell?
You know,
you haven't done anything.
Right.
You're like,
I tell 18 year old,
six years ago you were 12.
It's like,
what the hell do you know you,
you haven't,
you,
you're,
you're under the care of
your family or the state.
You haven't established
an independent existence.
You haven't had children.
You haven't started a business.
You haven't taken
responsibility for anything.
You don't have a degree.
You haven't finished your courses,
you don't know how to read.
You can't thank,
you can't speak.
You're,
you're,
you don't know how to present yourself.
Well Jesus,
you know,
and it's just not right to tell people
in that situation that they should go out
and change the socioeconomic,
what culture,
what those children,
those children are young
people that observe or not
wise adults managing complex
systems at that plea.
They see people giving subsidies
to fossil fuel companies.
They see people and just
teaching them a university or no,
like you're so hung up on
the university experience.
Like we keep coming back to this issue
of the activist at the university,
which is clearly very salient for you,
but for those who are not there,
it's frankly alienating
because you other workers,
so fantastic.
But it keeps coming back to this narrative
of these slightly callow students who
are maybe a bit over enthusiastic
about a political issue.
I'm more concerned with their
professors then with the stool.
Okay.
Also the support with the professors
completely corrupted the humanities
and the humanities are the core of the
university.
And by corrupting the humanities,
they're corrupting the fundamental
structure of our civilization and they're
spreading that out into
the general culture.
Right.
But then there's no excuse for that.
They may be doing that,
but simultaneously others are
corrupting the ecological foundations,
the social foundations.
Democracy is arguably dying.
There are real problems
that are existential threats
that are on a different
level.
There's multiple large variety of ways.
And I don't think that's happening
principally because some people are being
taught feminist theory and
the University of Toronto.
It's not that it's something else much
bigger and broader and deeper that when
people raise these issues,
you focus on that small issue,
not the big ones that
they're worried about.
Well,
it depends on the issue I suppose.
Um,
I would say for example,
just for argument's sake,
well what,
what should I say about climate change?
What should you do to drive here?
If you were,
no I didn't.
I didn't want,
what did you do?
How'd you do?
I took public transport,
but that's not really,
but again,
that's hardly the point.
Yeah.
Well the point,
because it's part of the problem with
climate change is irreducible complexity,
right?
It's like,
you know,
we,
there's a cost to our existence
and the cost is externalization,
right?
Externalization of costs and we
don't know how to manage that.
Right?
And I would say,
should we be concerned about it?
So like,
yeah,
absolutely.
Do we know how to be
concerned about it yet?
Not really.
[inaudible] right.
So,
so then how do we learn does that,
that becomes the question,
right?
So the younger generation who are,
who like give me an example more
directly affected the kinds of people in
developing countries and younger people
who feel the pinch of this all the
morning.
Cause they can see,
for example,
New York,
the chancellor thing underwater by by
the end of the century is not negligible
and therefore they're
looking for a response that
really matters to them.
And when you think about responsibility,
I think this number,
they're view is don't patronize me about
my bedroom when I've got the planet to
say
there is no,
no,
it's a boy.
I understand.
I think your bedroom is important,
right?
I mean do you think the whole
planet is more important?
They're more concerned about that.
And One why is your room is
a microcosm of the planet,
right?
Without tell.
Tell us about that then.
Well let's,
let's,
let's go back to the climate issue here
first because there's this guy that I'm
aware of.
His name is Boyan Slat and I'm going
to talk to him in the relatively near
future I think.
And he's a model for,
for young people.
He went out scuba diving when he was
17 and there was a lot of plastic,
you know,
and that sort of bothered him.
And then he started thinking about
Manta rays and how they move through the
water.
And then he noticed that most of the
plastic was in the top six inches.
And then he thought,
I wonder if I could build a machine that
was like a Manta ray that would float
on top of the water.
And anyways,
to make a long story short,
he's devised a way to rid 50% of the
plastic in the world's oceans within five
years and has spent the last six years
developing that and is well on the way to
implementing it.
And it looks like it might work and he's
going to be able to make a profit from
it just to add that extra bit of punch.
And so by on slot,
I would say it's like,
I don't know if his room was clean or not,
but there was something about him that
was dead on because when he looked at a
problem like that,
he thought,
I'm not going to go out there and tell
a bunch of other people what they're
doing wrong so that they can solve it.
I'm going to bloody well fix it.
And that's what I'm telling
young men in particular to do.
Although,
you know,
I'm feeling women want to do that.
It's like great.
More power to them,
but you know,
people say,
well,
I'm taking climate change seriously.
I'm going out to protests.
Like you're not taking it seriously.
That's not serious.
Serious is you're going to devote 80
hours of your life to it for the rest of
your life,
right?
You're going to work on that so intently
that you're not even going to think
about anything else that's here.